the new game of thrones prequel show has
begun with house of the dragon episode
1. it has a tournament a horrific
childbirth a secret prophecy lots of
dragons and matt smith's butt so what
does it all mean and how does the show
compare to the book this video has no
spoilers beyond episode 1 and the
original game of thrones show the
episode's called the heirs of the dragon
because that's the name of the chapter
in the book this show is based on fire
and blood the big question this episode
is succession who will inherit the
throne it starts with a flashback to the
council at harrenhal in the year 101
this is 200 years before game of thrones
and daenerys and jon snow and it's 100
years after aegon targaryen conquered
westeros and started the targaryen
dynasty at this time the king is jeharis
targaryen he was the fourth king of
westeros and he's seen as one of the
best kings ever his reign was peaceful
and prosperous he reformed laws and
built roads but jahiris had bad
relationships with some of the women in
his life the book says he was better
with roads than with daughters and
jiharis had a messy succession deciding
who would rule westeros after him
because originally jaehaerys's heir was
his eldest son aemon but aemon got
killed so then jiharis said his second
son balon was his heir even though aemon
had a daughter called rhaenys and some
people said rhaenys or her children
should inherit the throne but jiharis
chose balon and then balon died of
absorbed tummy so then jahiris was like
[ __ ] now what and he held this big
council to choose the new heir to the
throne
they held the council at harrenhal
because it's the biggest castle in
westeros it's also mostly ruined because
aegon the conqueror burned it with his
dragon a hundred years ago we see arya
at harrenhal in game of thrones
so the lords are here to choose an heir
and the main candidates are rhaenys
targaryen daughter of aemon and viserys
targaryen son of balon in the book
rhaenys's son leno is a more popular
candidate than rhaenys because he's male
and the lords prefer male rulers to
women
lenore's claim is supported by his
father carlos velaryon who's very rich
and influential
there are some other candidates the book
mentions jaehaerys's son vagon but he's
a nerd who no one likes and he's a
maester sworn to the citadel they also
mentioned jiharis's daughter sarah but
she's busy running a brothel in the east
one of sarah's bastard sons turns up
with an elephant but the lords aren't
impressed they consider lenore and
rhaenys but in the end they choose
viserys to be the next king mostly
because he's an adult male who inherits
through the male line many lords see
this as an iron precedent that the
throne will always be inherited by men
to the great frustration of rhaenys and
her family
the books say that viserys won this vote
by 20-1 though the maesters who counted
the votes never revealed the numbers so
some fans speculate that the maesters
rigged the vote to choose the heir they
wanted some characters in the books say
that maesters have a conspiracy against
dragons and while lenore has the dragon
sea smoke and rhaenys rides the dragon
melis viserys doesn't ride a dragon
because his dragon balerion died so
maybe the maesters rigged the vote for
viserys because they preferred a king
who didn't have a dragon but that's just
a theory point is viserys becomes heir
to the throne and the episode continues
about 10 years later when viserys is now
king we see his daughter princess
rhaenyra flying her dragon cyrax she
parks her dragon at the dragon pit which
is like a big stable where the dragons
live
we see the dragonpit in game of thrones
200 years later when it's become a ruin
the dragonpit is guarded by the dragon
keepers the books describe them as proud
warriors in gleaming scaled armor but in
hot d they're a monk-like order in grimy
robes maybe scooping dragon poop is part
of their job this one seems to have a
dragonglass dagger which is interesting
dragonglass is a special volcanic
material that can kill white walkers the
dragon keepers command dragons in the
valyrian language which came from
valyria the ancient empire of the
original dragon lords rhaenyra's dragon
cyrax is named after a valyrian goddess
so rhaenyra puts her dragon in daycare
and we meet harold westerling he's a
member of the kingsguard and the sworn
protector of princess rhaenyra the
targaryen royal family live in the red
keep and we see the cape full of lords
and courtiers in rich and colorful
clothing this is the political center of
the realm in a time of prosperity and
splendor this courtyard is the same
place where cersei lannister paints a
map of westeros 200 years later
rhaenyra visits her mother emma aaron
the wife and queen of king viceros
emma's mother was a targaryen so she and
viserys are cousins emma doesn't like it
when rhaenyra goes flying like in game
of thrones when catelyn doesn't like it
when bran goes climbing emma is pregnant
and she tells rhaenyra that it's the
duty of a lady to make babies for the
realm but rhaenyra says she'd rather be
a knight and ride in battle it's like in
game of thrones when arya doesn't want
to marry and have kids so while emma
seems resigned to her role in the
patriarchy rhaenyra dreams of a
different life
rhaenyra serves as cupbearer on king
viserys's small council his councillors
are otto hightower hand of the king
lionel strong master of laws melos the
grand maester lyman beesberry master of
coin and corliss velaryon master of
ships though at this point in the book
corliss had quit the council because he
was angry about his wife rhaenys and son
lana not getting the throne at the
harrenhal council
each councillor has a round stone to
represent their presence we also see
ryam redwine the commander of the
kingsguard ryam has been on the
kingsguard for some 50 years and he's a
legendary knight at one point king
jiharis made ryam the hand of the king
but ryam was a terrible hand so jiharis
had to fire him turns out that being a
good knight doesn't make you a good
politician
corliss warns the council about the
triarchy the triarchy is an alliance of
the eastern cities of tyrosh mir and lis
they've started attacking pirates on the
stepstones these little islands between
westeros and essos corliss is worried
that if the triarchy take control of the
stepstones they could disrupt trade up
the narrow sea callers's family the
valarions are based on driftmark in the
narrow sea and they make their money off
this trade so like all good prequels
this show might start with a trade
dispute but the other councillors don't
care about the stepstones and they
discuss the upcoming tournament and
queen emma's pregnancy we see viserys
eating an egg which is a symbol of
fertility and birth though the way
viserys cracks the egg open is a dark
omen of how emma's pregnancy ends
rhaenyra sees her uncle prince daemon
targaryen daemon sits on the throne
which he's not meant to do showing his
desire for power and willingness to
break rules daemon and rhaenyra speak in
valyrian and he gives her a necklace of
valyrian steel the special magic steel
that was made in valyria just like
daemon has a sword of valyrian steel
called dark sister and apparently
daemon's helmet is also made of valyrian
steel so the targaryens in this time
celebrate their valyrian ancestry
despite the fact that the valyrians were
pretty evil their empire killed and
enslaved thousands of people yet the
targaryens see them as role models
rhaenyra hangs out with her friend
alison hightower alison wants to study
and be a proper lady but rhaenyra wants
adventure and cake allison and rhaenyra
are kind of like the lady-like sansa and
rebellious arya except instead of being
rivals alison and rhaenyra are close
friends they talk about nymeria a
warrior queen from the east who lived a
thousand years ago nymeria led her
people on a great migration and found a
new homeland in dawn nymeria left a
legacy in dawn of female power and
equality hbo has worked on a potential
spin-off show about nymeria and despite
rhaenyra's rebellious attitude she does
know all about nymeria showing that
she's smart and that she's aware of a
great female leader which again is like
arya arya named her direwolf after
nymeria
we see that the red keep has a weirwood
tree weirwoods with their red leaves and
carved faces are the sacred trees of the
old gods the magic power that bran
connects to in game of thrones in the
books there is no weirwood in the red
cape most weirwoods were destroyed in
the south when the new religion of the
seven took over so this is an
interesting change will the magic of the
old gods have a role in this story
king viserys has cuts on his body that
he got from sitting the iron throne the
throne is made of sharp swords making it
impossible to sit on comfortably and
aegon the conqueror made it that way
deliberately this dangerous throne
symbolizes that kings must use power
carefully and wisely or else their power
will destroy them when a king is cut by
the iron throne that hints that the king
isn't handling power well the mad king
aerys ii the father of daenerys cuts
himself on the throne so often that he's
called king scab
king maegor the cruel died on the throne
and some say he was killed by the throne
as though the throne rejects unworthy
kings so it's very ominous that the
throne cuts viserys and that the wound
is not healing
viserys visits his pregnant wife emma
emma jokes that she might hatch a dragon
which is interesting because several
targaryens in the books give birth to
deformed babies with dragon-like
features daenerys gives birth to a
stillborn that is scaled like a lizard
with leathery wings the reason for this
might be that the targaryens have the
blood of the dragon their valyrian
ancestors claimed that they were
literally descended from dragons like
with dragon dna which is probably what
allows them to control dragons emma is
having a bad time with her pregnancy
she's already had multiple stillbirths
and miscarriages the book says that emma
and viserys first had sex when she was
just 13 and some maesters say that she
got pregnant too young and this damaged
her health but viserys keeps wanting
more kids because he wants a son to
inherit his throne viserys is convinced
that their unborn child is male because
he had a dream of a son and targaryens
do have prophetic dreams of the future
the whole political stability of
westeros depends on queens producing
male heirs so emma is reluctantly
dragged along with her husband's dream
though she says that she can't do this
again
viserys's brother daemon is the
commander of the gold cloaks the city
watch of king's landing and he leads a
brutal violent crackdown on alleged
criminals in the city we see daemon
personally kill a murderer with dark
sister the book says that daemon
delights in mutilating criminals cutting
off hands and noses and [ __ ] so this is
not just about law enforcement this is
about daemon enjoying violence spreading
fear and asserting his power the gold
cloaks are like his personal loyal army
two thousand strong in the heart of the
realm
otto hightower is angry about this
bloodbath he wants to reduce daemon's
power and to prevent him getting the
throne daemon responds like a smirking
sulky teenager who's acting out for
attention he misbehaves because he wants
his brother viserys to notice him and
accept him
daemon has sex with his lover mazaria
but daemon can't climax he feels
unsatisfied with pent-up feelings that
he can't seem to let out it's like the
only ways daemon knows how to feel
better is through sex and violence and
if that doesn't work for him what will
mazaria suggests that daemon have sex
with a silver-haired maiden which is
interesting because daemon's niece
rhaenyra is a silver-headed maiden who
he seemed pretty close to earlier
daemon is stressed because if emma gives
birth to a son that son will replace
daemon as heir to the throne
viserys holds a big tournament to
celebrate the coming birth of his child
there's jousting and fighting and
there's politics lord boremond baratheon
competes he's an ancestor of robert
stannis and renly baratheon barmand is
also the uncle of rhaenys targaryen and
at the harrenhal council he supported
rhaenys and lenore in their claim for
the throne so now borromand calls
rhaenys the queen who never was it is a
little treasonous to publicly undermine
king viserys by bringing up rhaenys's
claim but viserys is chill and he allows
the light treason
prince daemon joins the tourney and he
chooses to joust against queen hightower
the son of otto hightower specifically
to piss off otto he also requests the
favor of otto's daughter allison so
daemon really is a master of annoying
otto
some of the knights start killing each
other on the tourney grounds which
you're not meant to do but it does
happen like in game of thrones when the
mountain attacks loris and the hound
rhaenys says these nights are green as
summer grass they're young and dumb and
full of come and have never experienced
real war or hard times it's similar to a
bit in the books when catelyn says that
winter is coming for the nights of
summer this is about loss of innocence
disillusionment the inevitable end of
all good times the surprise favorite of
the tournament is kristen cole kristen
isn't from some rich and famous family
he's the son of a steward and in hot d
he's dornish which is unusual because in
this time period dawn has not yet been
conquered by the targaryens it's still
an independent kingdom with its own laws
and culture so kristen is an outsider
and an underdog and he has a lot to gain
by proving himself with his fighting
skills kristin defeats the famous prince
daemon in jousting and combat partly by
attacking daemon while he wasn't looking
though to be fair daemon also played
dirty by tripping gwen hightower's horse
with his lance everyone's breaking the
rules here but kristen wins and he
clearly makes an impression on rhaenyra
and alison
meanwhile emma's childbirth goes wrong
melos says that emma is gonna die and
the only way to save the baby is to cut
it out of her like a medieval c-section
which will kill emma viserys is
horrified but he wants his male heir so
he agrees to cut his wife open to save
his child they don't ask emma what she
wants
so they start the bloody procedure and
it's intercut with knights fighting at
the tourney the battlefield of men and
the birthing bed of women as two sides
in an endless violent cycle of death and
life
emma dies and viserys gets his baby son
and names him balon but then balon dies
too from birth complications maybe so at
the funeral the baby balon is cremated
along with queen emma
in the books emma just dies in
childbirth it doesn't mention a
c-section but that does happen to a
different character in the book alyssa
velaryon alyssa was the mother of king
jiharis and of borrom and baratheon by
her second husband roga rogar kept
getting alissa pregnant even though she
was too old and it was dangerous for her
her next childbirth went bad and like
viserys rogar chose to cut his wife open
to save the baby because he wanted a son
alyssa's daughter rayna was furious at
rogar for this she blamed him for
alyssa's death because he got her
pregnant when it was dangerous for her
and she was angry that he valued his
wife's life less than he valued making a
son we can see a hint of that anger on
rhaenyra's face when she looks at
viserys and then says dracarus
fire
cause this episode highlights how much
rhaenyra cares for her mother and how
frustrated she is the vicerous seems to
care more about getting a son than he
cares about his wife and daughter
rhaenyra sees emma dead because of
viserys's dream and she resents being
pushed into the same gender role that
killed her mother
after the funeral the council talks
succession it's very dangerous when
there's no clear air to the throne
because competing claims often lead to
war precedent says that vasaris's
brother daemon is next in line but most
folks don't want daemon on the throne
because he's violent and unpredictable
otto suggests rhaenyra as heir and
corliss suggests rhaenys but lionel
argues there's never been a female ruler
so viserys storms off leaving the future
of the realm hanging in limbo otto
decides to act he tells his daughter
allison to put on her mother's dress and
go comfort the newly single king viserys
in his bed chamber otto is similar to
tywin lannister in game of thrones he's
being hand writing letters and using his
children for his political ambitions
alison finds viserys working on a model
city using a nerdy hobby to cope with
his grief
the city looks similar to dragonstone
but bigger it might represent old
valyria or maybe viserys is imagining a
grand expansion to the dragonstone
castle there was once another targaryen
king who dreamed of a white city the mad
king heiress some fans have noticed that
the model city looks like the opening
sequence to game of thrones
meanwhile daemon has his own way of
coping with emotions he drinks alone
fully clothed in the middle of an orgy
he set up for his gold cloaks mazaria
prompts him to speak and daemon gives a
toast to viserys's dead baby calling him
the heir for a day as though celebrating
that with balon's death daemon remains
heir to the throne otto tells viserys
about this so viserys confronts daemon
and turns all his grief for his wife and
child into fury at his brother daemon
gets angry back and calls viserys weak
so viserys finally decides to disinherit
daemon and sends him away to the veil
it's tragic that these two brothers who
love each other fight when they should
be supporting each other immediately
after viserys again cuts himself on the
throne another dark omen
so viserys and daemon are separated and
that was probably otto's plan this is
why he told viserys about daemon's toast
daemon says that otto is an ambitious
scheming [ __ ] and otto himself said that
all men want
power at the same time that otto pushes
daemon away he moves his daughter
alicent closer to the king
viserys decides to make his daughter
rhaenyra heir to the throne he says he
was wrong to focus on an unborn son when
rhaenyra all along had the potential to
be a great ruler though viserys knows
that the throne is a terrible
responsibility he knows the danger of
dragons and of power he talks about
valyria how their power and pride led to
their downfall though the exact cause of
the doom of valyria is a mystery viserys
tells rhaenyra a big secret so a hundred
years ago aegon targaryen took over
westeros and started the line of
targaryen kings viserys says that part
of why aegon conquered westeros is
because he had a dream of a winter from
the north that would destroy humanity
aegon had a dream of the white walkers
and aegon believed that a targaryen king
must unite the realm to save the world
from the white walkers and that's why he
conquered westeros
this dream of aegon's isn't in the books
but it was author george martin's idea
to add this to the show and in the books
there are other targaryens who know
about a prophecy to save the world aemon
jairus ii probably bloodraven and
rhaegar targaryen the brother of
daenerys and the father of jon snow the
books say that when rhaegar was young he
found something in some scrolls that
convinced him to become a warrior maybe
rhaegar discovered aegon's white walker
dream daenerys has a vision of rhaegar
where rhaegar mentions the song of ice
and fire and viserys says that aegon's
dream is called the song of ice and fire
this prophecy is probably why rhaegar
ran off with lyanna and had jon snow he
must have believed that his son would
stop the white walkers finally
fulfilling aegon's dream of the
targaryens saving the world
of course we know that this prophecy
doesn't exactly come true in game of
thrones season 8 the white walkers are
not defeated by a targaryen or by a
united westeros arya stark kills the
white walkers and at the time westeros
is divided with cersei lannister on the
throne so maybe this dream was
misinterpreted aegon was right about the
white walkers but he was wrong to think
that his family would be the saviors
it's like how viserys misinterprets his
dream about his heir he was right that
there'd be thundering hooves and
splintering shields and his air on the
throne but he was wrong to assume that
his heir was a son
in the books prophecies and dreams are
often misinterpreted due to character's
ambition and biases which often leads to
their downfall as marwyn says prophecy
will bite your prick off every time
viserys wears this valyrian steel dagger
and this is the same dagger that arya
uses to kill the night king in game of
thrones the same dagger that she uses to
kill littlefinger the same dagger in
this book sam found the same dagger that
an assassin used against catelyn and
bran and that littlefinger lied about to
start the whole war and got season 1. so
is this special dagger part of the
prophecy or is it just some cosmic
coincidence that this is the knife that
saves the world
the showrunners say that they included
this prophecy and this knife to raise
the stakes in hot d and to connect it
with the conflict in game of thrones
viserys tells rhaenyra to promise him to
keep this secret dream just like ned
stark promises lyanna to keep the secret
of jon snow
there's a big ceremony where the lords
of the realm swear loyalty to rhaenyra
and promise to support her claim to the
throne when viserys dies she is set to
become the first female ruler of
westeros but this moment isn't all
triumphant it feels dangerous
daemon is angry that he's been replaced
rhaenys and her family have been snubbed
again otto is plotting and some of these
lords don't look happy about a female
heir this does go against the president
of the harrenhal council and rhaenyra
never wanted any of this all she wanted
was to fly and have fun and eat cake but
now she not only has to rule the
continent she has to save it from the
frosty apocalypse because her
great-great-great-grandpa had a dream
all the power and dreams of house
targaryen weigh upon her and the theme
of this episode is that power and dreams
are dangerous
house of the dragon is based on the book
fire and blood season 1 covers chapter
12 heirs of the dragon there's also a
shorter summary of the story in the book
the world of ice and fire starting in
the vicerous chapter so if you want to
know the full story of house of the
dragon from beginning to end with all
the spoilers you can get either of these
audiobooks for free right now at
audible.com asx sign up for a premium
plus trial membership and you get an
audiobook to keep even if you cancel the
trial you can get any game of thrones
book or lord of the rings or dune and
membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audio books and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com asx or text asx to 500
500.
thanks for watching we're doing a house
of the dragon live stream every sunday
at about 10 15 p.m eastern time and
doing an explained video like this each
week so like and subscribe press the
bell follow the twitter and thanks to
the supporters on patreon including
lance duncan brookover rachel krangel
the bastard daughter courtney budlik
pedro coelho and matt cheers